Bob good to see you hey come here how
are you I'm doing pretty well you know
there's a lot to talk about here and
these are really strange times and then
I just found out that you have had a
personal brush with this coronavirus
madness yeah my son Nate who's 21 was it
to Paul and his roommate was sick really
really sick and my son had asthma for
many years and very bad I mean a lot of
times that goes away around 18 or so but
he he was even at 20 and I think he
still uses an inhaler sometimes so when
I met him at the airport and I gave him
a mask and you know he washed his hands
with antibacterial soap and all that
stuff right and he woke up the next
morning with a fever and he said his
throat hurt like it had cancer and he
said it really hurt and he said he was
debilitated for weeks right two weeks
pretty much two weeks you know to the
point where we're just so used to the
flu and we can't our brains just
naturally go oh come on I've been
through it I get it three days to three
days that are hard and then you get
better and it's just not that it's not
that it's much worse and yeah so two
weeks in he's still I'm like looking at
him I'm going you're you're good now
right you you're doing good right and
he's like no no I'm not good it's like
the power of positive thinking I know
that thing where you're trying to you're
trying to willed people to be better
like yeah good you look you look fine
right no no how many feet do you have
I'm seeing two feet I'm seeing arms
moving around